[Musica]
buongiorno io sono davide da tre sono
l'amministrato delegato di sound res spa
che un concorrente della siae italia è
un concorrente di tante altre sia e in
europa
oggi vi voglio raccontare la storia di
questa industria che una storia molto
particolare e cosa si può fare di nuovo
in quest'industria allora prima di tutto
come funziona questo mercato perché noi
siamo abituati a leggere sui giornali il
mercato di spotify di apple quindi
business to consumer ma questo il
mercato delle sia il mercato
completamente differente un mercato che
non leggete sui giornali è un mercato
che si occupa da una parte di autori
editori e dall'altra di utilizzatori
commerciali quindi ogni volta ogni volta
che una musica passa in radio in
televisione o per esempio quelle musiche
avete sentito durante il break o
la musica che sentite in un punto
vendita
ogni volta che sentite quel passaggio
radiofonico televisivo comunque
utilizzazione di musical autore editore
spetta un compenso questo compenso è
stato tipicamente gestito negli ultimi
100 anni e passa dalle società di
gestione dei compensi in italia da siae
ed è un mercato molto grande in europa
vale 6 miliardi in italia il fatturato
della siae e 700 milioni oltre 700
milioni al considerate che è talmente
importante questo mercato nell'italia
che la siae inglese cioè il paese patria
della musica fattura quanto la siae
italiana e pensate che le tristi a e
statunitensi fatturano il doppio della
serie a italiana è sproporzionato no
quindi è un mercato molto ricco e
pensate anche che nel momento in cui
tutta l'industria la musica crollava
cioè dal 2003 al 2011 il momento in cui
leggiamo sui giornali che tutti quanti
saranno difficoltà questo settore del
mercato è cresciuto del 23 per cento dal
2003 al 2011 mentre sui giornali
leggevamo del crollo dell'industria la
musica quindi per farvi capire che è un
settore diverso da quello che conoscete
con regole diverse e come è stato
gestito questo mercato da sempre negli
ultimi 100 anni e passa alla siae a
oltre 130 anni pensate è stato gestito
da 28 società in 28 paesi in europa
ogni società un paese strano come un
mercato no neanche l'acqua è così se poi
pensate
l'acqua a livello europeo non è così
molto interessante da un punto di vista
economico no e infatti io mi sono
cominciate a interessare a questo
mercato all'università perché piaceva
molto l'antitrust ho fatto economia mi
piaceva moltissimo antitrust dicevo ma
come è possibile che ci abbiamo 28 paesi
28 società e come fanno a scambiarsi i
soldi questi paesi con accordi di
reciprocità
io incasso qui al paese mio perché sia
inglese tu sia inglese incassi per me
sul territorio inglese ma perché abbiamo
creato un mercato di questo tipo in
origine aveva assolutamente senso aveva
assolutamente senso
1 la protezione territoriale degli
autori editori cioè senza internet senza
tecnologie ma come facevi ad andare in
ogni casa in ogni chiesa in ogni posto a
vedere chi suonava la musica ea chiedere
un compenso per quella musica perché è
giusto chiedere un compenso per quella
musica e sono soldi di autori editori
che altrimenti non vivrebbero non
riuscirebbero a produrre musica non
riuscirebbero a produrre qualità e
cultura quindi è giusto la protezione
territoriale di diritti e degli autori e
la seconda ragione la concertazione
collettiva cosa c'è di più giusto della
concertazione collettiva quando è
sproporzionata la forza tra chi compra e
chi vende no e quindi era giusto che gli
autori editori si aggregassero in una
grande diciamo società che facesse gli
interessi magari il regime di monopolio
di tutto ma c'è un problema grande
utopia cattiva realizzazione cioè noi
voglio dire io non aveva mai creato
sound rif
se questa roba funzionava perché che
cosa c'è di più bello di una grande
società che si occupa non profit di
80.000 autori editori italiani e che ne
fa il bene bellissimo no
purtroppo però quando c'è il monopolio
abbiamo studiato dall università in poi
che ci stanno gravi inefficienze che non
funziona effettivamente che nella
maggior parte dei casi questa roba non
funziona e non funziona proprio per
coloro che dovevano essere protetti ai
piccoli autori e picco i piccoli medi
autori e perché non funziona perché
mancava completamente manca ancora la
distribuzione analitica delle royalty
c'è che cosa significa significa che la
siae
e le altre società di gestione dei
compensi andava a raccogliere 200 euro
da loro che hanno messo i brani durante
il break o le mille euro dal
supermercato o le 10 mila euro dalla
radio locale o quello che sia ma non
divideva e non divide secondo ciò che è
stato effettivamente suonato ma tv the
secondo i criteri decisi dal consiglio
di gestione cioè dal consiglio di
amministrazione centrale io raccolgo 700
milioni di euro e una parte importante e
rilevante oltre il 60 per cento di
questi soldi con raccolto non li divide
secondo ciò che è stato effettivamente
suonato ma l'individuo secondo ciò che
ha deciso un piccolo consiglio da
gestione di gestione cioè cinque persone
più consiglio di sorveglianza formato da
15 persone mi sembra giusto a voi con la
tecnologia di oggi secondo noi non era
giusto e due è giusto lavorare oggi e
pagare essere pagati dopo 36 mesi cioè
tu accetteresti di essere pagato o di e
di lavorare oggi di essere pagato dopo
36 mesi
no e perché dovrebbero tutti gli autori
editori perché questi sono i tempi
rendicontazioni la tua musica è usata
oggi è verificato dopo 18 24 mesi e
quando vieni pagato
cioè se rientri ripartizioni decise dal
consiglio di gestione
dopo 24 mesi pari a st assegno sostegno
c'è scritto mille euro a tanto da
guadagnare se mille euro a tatore ma se
capisce se c'è scritto radio 500 euro ho
capito quale canale è che ora quale
momento qual è stato il meccanismo per
pagarmi non c'è niente
cioè quando noi abbiamo iniziato dal
2011 non c'è niente fondamentalmente
c'era sostanzialmente dei flussi di
denaro che andavano verso dove nitore
senza capire bene da dove provenissero
c'è un'intera industria da ricostruire
da ricostruire da un punto di vista
prima e tutto tecnologico ma finalmente
a volte le cose belle succedono no e
quindi noi iniziamo nel 2011 pensando
che prima o poi la comunità europea
poteva andare a metter fine a questa
roba nel 2014 mette fine direttiva
barnier tutte i paesi membri
le società di gestione nei paesi membri
alcuni da europea devono farsi
concorrenza e possono nascere per la
prima volta ciò che viene chiamato
l'ente di gestione indipendente cioè
sandri società private in concorrenza
con i vecchi monopolisti facciamo che
forse era bellissimo è riuscita a dire
ti amo domani laurea
cominciamo a lavorare alla grande in
realtà nasce una grossissima diciamo
polemica politica legale che ancora va
avanti e notizia di qualche giorno fa lo
da fittipaldi su l'espresso che la siae
già registrato e spiato illegalmente per
circa 12 mesi fondamentalmente no queste
notizia di quattro giorni ma soltanto
per farvi capire il livello dello
scontro
a marzo 2017 ramo completamente fuori
dal mercato per una legge fatta contro
di noi ea ottobre 2017 la legge viene
ribaltata semplicemente su
sollecitazione dell'antitrust la
commissione europea
l'antitrust in questo o in questi mesi
sta finendo un'indagine contro se hai
con dodici capi d'accusa per concorrenza
sleale nei nostri confronti
quindi in realtà la festa era finita
soltanto nelle nostre teste
poi chissà quando finirà veramente ma
ciò di cui veramente vi voglio parlare e
cosa si può fare perché in realtà a noi
tutta sta polemica politica e legale c'è
veramente stufato noi siamo gente che
vuole fare tecnologia punto fine e di
questo vi voglio parlare perché vi ho
raccontato prima che non si poteva fare
il controllo territoriale senza la
tecnologia senza un certo tipo di
tecnologia ma oggi si può fare è la
prima cosa che le prime due cose che
sono importantissime per questo
progresso che ci permette di andare a
fare le cose in maniera diversa sono che
la musica è diventata digitale
ovviamente e quindi diciamo puoi fare
tutta una serie di cose banale ma molto
importante 2 che esistono delle tecniche
di riconoscimento audio automatiche cioè
io posso ascoltare per esempio decine di
migliaia canali televisivi radiofonici e
dare una rendicontazione in tempo reale
di quello che vi ascolto sulle radio
sulla televisione una specie di
gigantesco shazam lo facciamo queste
cose e ciò che facciamo oggi quindi
ricordatevi la rendicontazione in 18
mesi adesso la facciamo in tempo reale
su radio tv quindi pensate quanto si può
innovare in questo spazio
e pensate quanto questo spazio sia
diverso e per ognuna di queste classi
l'innovazione è diversa i ragionamenti
sono diversi anche da un punto di vista
legale perché se parliamo di radio
televisioni è un mercato molto
concentrato cioè i broadcaster tv sono
45 i broadcaster radiofonici quelli
importanti sono una decina
poi ci stanno quelli locali 200 diciamo
come dire non hai bisogno di una rete di
ispettori territoriali che vanno in giro
per l'italia si sa fa che per quanto
riguarda invece il piccolo negozio
all'angolo effettivamente hai bisogno
diciamo di una certa rete che controlla
anche il territorio ma anche lì potresti
fare tantissimo potresti portare questi
esercizi commerciali ad utilizzare un
decoder e magari con degli incentivi e
quel decoder dentro a dei meccanismi di
riconoscimento dell'audio si può fare
veramente tanto
e la cosa peggiore da fare in assoluto e
dire che questo mercato è un mercato
unico che vale per tutti che vale per
tutte le classi no queste classi sono
effettivamente nicchie di mercato molto
differenti e devono essere gestite da un
punto di vista legale e commerciale il
tecnologico in maniera differente e
questo rende questo mercato molto
interessante
vi faccio degli esempi come si può
accelerare questo progresso come si può
rendere questa industria finalmente più
moderna 1 velo raccontato prima
rendiconto emorragie monitoraggio audio
automatici cioè ascolto continuamente
flussi di musica in determinati posti e
cominciò a raccogliere in maniera
automatica milioni e milioni di dati su
ciò che è stato suonato i dati
dell'industria musicale ormai in
qualsiasi industria usiamo i dati
nell'industria musica i dati sono
considerati poco una carta igienica
praticamente dicevamo c'è nel senso
stiamo proprio la considerazione dei
dati e industria così è quasi nulla
fondamentalmente in realtà è un settore
che si fonda sui dati o si dovrebbe
fondare sui dati 2 la gestione integrità
dei dati insieme a preservazione alla
cronologia dei dati cioè voi pensate che
non esiste un database una specie di
catasto degli immobili per esempio dove
diciamo uno può andare a verificare la
proprietà degli un immobile non esiste
né industria musica cioè non esiste un
database centrale che registra la
proprietà di un brano e come questa
proprietà cambiare gli anni non esiste
non esiste
per farvi capire lo stato dell'industria
e voi capite che un brano voi pensate
che un brano è molto simile a una
società un immobile un brano può essere
di proprietà di 10 20 persone un brano
famoso è di proprietà di 10 20 soggetti
privati fisici che hanno privilegi
diversi quindi al bisogno di una certa
centralità e di una certa integrità dei
dati ma soprattutto quando io comincia a
raccogliere miliardi i dati da tutti
questi dorizza tori e comincia a
registrare le transazioni cioè io ho
raccolto un euro da quello di licenza e
ha suonato dieci brani
io sto raccogliendo delle informazioni
preziose che devono essere verificate in
futuro io eventi finito devo poter
andare continuamente online e vedere se
effettivamente quella transizione
venuto e come avvenuta perché senza
tracciabilità io sto nell'ignoranza e
gli autori e gli editori hanno vissuto
nei una nube di ignoranza per decenni
quindi la prima cosa che dobbiamo fare è
schiarire questa nube dell'ignoranza con
la tecnologia 3 rendicontazione in tempo
reale una volta che ciò tutti i dati sul
digitale io posso cominciare a fare
delle cose veramente molto interessanti
e posso cominciare a dare dei dati in
maniera molto veloce dati e soldi
ovviamente e finisco dicendo e finisco
raccontando co come la blow cene che è
un qualcosa di abusato secondo me come
termine rispetto alla musica nel senso
quello che vedo in giro è schifezza
spazzatura e ne alcuni molti casi invece
truffe vere e proprie ma in realtà da
bluocean se utilizzate una certa maniera
può aiutare tantissimo
l'industria musica a migliorarsi uno
quello che vi ho raccontato prima un
database per un proof of ownership per
una prova di proprietà sui brani è
un'applicazione assolutamente intuitiva
per la blow cene labbro ce ne è perfetta
in quel caso perché ci costruisce un
un ambiente decentralizzato che non può
essere effettivamente alterato da i
proprietari di quel database
fondamentalmente a maggior ragione se
poi noi quel database in quel leggerlo
sviluppiamo in open source e quindi a
disposizione diciamo di tutta una serie
di soggetti che lavorano nell'industria
2 l'immagazzinamento e preservazione
delle utilizzazioni della musica cioè
noi
uscito di nuovo un articolo qualche
giorno fa che raccontava come questi
rendiconti della siae fossero strani voi
pensate tutti voi conoscete
andiamo a comandare di ragazzi e vorrei
ma non posso dire che sono due singoli
diciamo che sono andati abbastanza
diciamo famosi possono piacere o non
piacere ma sono diventati molto famosi
voi pensate che questo giornalista due
giorni fa ha riportato che il rendiconto
di ragazzi era stato pagato per l'anno
2012 ma quell'anno 12 roma si stava
macca diceva nel 2 nel 2012 e vorrei ma
un posto nel 2013 ma con fede era anni
prima per farvi capire quindi è molto
importante che noi costruiamo diciamo
portiamo questi dati sulla brace né per
più sicurezza per evitare che siano
corrotti per la preservazione per futuro
controllo e 3
la cosa veramente che credo sia più
importante in assoluto e poi chiudo e
ricominciare ad avere fiducia tra gli
interlocutori utilizzatore che ha
fiducia nella autore di tore autore
editore che ha fiducia non intermediario
perché io penso che se abbiamo un
piccolo negozio e paghiamo 50 euro di
licenza ci fa molto piacere sapere che
quelle 50 euro vanno veramente a finire
all'autore editore e nonché quelle 50
euro siano percepite come nathan
l'ennesima tassa che paghiamo e non
capiamo dove andranno a finire quei
soldi quindi se noi ricostruiamo un
circolo di fiducia di trasparenza e di
solidarietà all'interno dell'industria
musica possiamo spostare l'asticella in
alto rispetto a
equità trasparenza e condivisione dei
della cultura vi ringrazio molto
[Musica]